right after russia decided to go ahead
and invade ukraine many countries around
the world all got together and they
decided what were the financial
sanctions that we were going to levy
against the country of russia now
everyone from the oligarchs to various
people within government organizations
and the country itself are being cut off
from various parts of the global
financial system some countries are
freezing assets other countries are
saying you can't raise debt or equity
capital in our markets and even others
are saying our banks will not do
business with your banks but now of
course russia is actually a really
really important trade partner for many
countries around the world they provide
12
of the oil production globally 17 of
natural gas production they also happen
to have a big say in things like wheat
corn and many other commodities as well
but india india has a trade relationship
with russia it's really important for
india actually to be able to trade with
russia to continue to serve their
citizens and so ultimately india is now
working on a workaround india is trying
to figure out how can we trade with
russia and not be impacted by these
sanctions from the western countries and
so what they're doing is they're
creating this rupee payment mechanism
that rupee payment mechanism allows them
to trade with russia to circumvent u.s
and allied sanctions and of course
there's a very strong argument for
financial sanctions but sanctions are
also going to accelerate adoption of
non-us dollar systems now this brand new
rupee system was created in 2012 and is
continuously being popularized and what
we see is that they're trying to protect
this trade between their country and
russia russia to india it's got seven
billion dollars last year it's mainly
mineral oils fertilizer and rough
diamonds that india to russia trade was
worth about half 3.3 billion dollars
last year and that's mainly
pharmaceutical products tea and coffee
now of course fertilizer is really
really important india needs that
fertilizer to be able to continue to
produce food and to serve their billion
plus people within their country but
don't be surprised that countries are
starting to recognize if financial
censorship is going to happen we have to
build an alternative solution we have to
be able to still trade with our trade
partners that's exactly what india is
doing we've got this quote here that
says this is a proactive move assuming
that the conflict escalates and there
could be a slew of sanctions in place in
this case we would not be able to settle
the transaction in dollars and so an
arrangement has been proposed to set up
a rupee account which is being
considered ultimately the u.s dollar
system is the global reserve currency
and the financial sanctions coming from
the united states work if countries use
dollars but if you're gonna sanction
dollars and people still need to trade
they're gonna simply just find a
different system that's exactly what
india and russia are attempting to do
here